just a quick disclaimer I'm not a DBA so
if you see something stupid or obvious
things that need to go right wait just
call me out I'm a Django
I hope I'm Django but and you can see
anything code issues because I did that
last two days you know more than happy
to request my by the cone and so just
were you out there so so she's
everywhere right so I was an expectation
that we had from our platform was the
students were supposed to search for
content so it could be for students who
are taking the same classes of courses
or searching for research articles or
some of the recommended reading
professor I was given out so it was
pretty intense
searching that was required for there
and it was a full text search so you can
put in just simple English like you know
professor you know Captain Kirk did this
specific topic so you won't actually
search and give English like search
keywords just like how you do it in
Google and you want some linguistic
support you want ranking so basically
whether fondness was that they wanted
articles to be the ones who are latest
come on the top versus ranking on
articles that are old to be on the
bottom so that's something that they
wanted and then there's a fuzzy
searching which is basically two typed
in spelling mistakes it should still
give you results at least the later
results not necessarily exact
and lastly more like this so if I looked
at an article which you've see this
every day and I spent hours on it if I
see a video on YouTube I end up going
through ten other recommended videos and
by the times two hours so you know
something like that we need we need or
excuse me we needed that in our platform
so we we had all these requirements and
we the time-to-market goes everything so
we wanted to see okay what can we do at
least to start off and we have these
options basically which was solar
electric elasticsearch cloud search and
Sphinx and you name it but the time to
do all configuration for these is just a
long time right so I mean solar itself
it takes ice Java so you know of Java
and then there is an elastic search
which is actually pretty good we're
moving towards that I would highly
recommend you guys look into that and
then there's cloud search which is
pretty interesting it's a little
expensive but it really does take care
of all of your so needs and I'll kind of
come back to that in a second and sphynx
I don't know a lot about it it's there
it's written in Python so if you are
brave enough to go check it out but all
of these require some degree of
knowledge of those tools and we were
pretty pretty good with Postgres already
and we knew that post rest has had
offers some degree of search so why not
just try it out so so just go back to
this slide so we know Ingenico most
people use I contain which is a dumbed
down version of search right I mean
that's a very kind of go to in a phrase
for that searching across the tables is
really a pain and you that you cannot
really control um if you control it you
end up writing your custom sequel or the
word I'm tech or RM takes care of all of
the joints
there's no relevancy no ranking you can
do fuzzy searching so it's just
basically limited you know you just
certainly doing searches in Django or
for that matter you know straight up
suppose got searches so what we did then
is we looked into Postgres and thank
directions there some of these some of
these social features are amazing
they're all written see there are really
good extensions and we were pretty
amazed how fast
Postgres is compared to solar compared
to other search engines and so we
started going into that and once you go
this go down the rabbit hole you end up
finding more and more new search
features and be like okay at this point
you're a post-grad shop and then you end
up giving a speech of course we're so so
that's something that we looked into its
really fast very very simple to
implement if you already been using
Postgres this should come very natural
to you and on top of it it supports
ranking boosting fuzzy search and the
list goes on and they continue to add
new things so please check out the
latest versions on some of the great
fuzzy searching algorithms right now so
live example let's try to find that if
you can find it there we go so I really
took this in like few hours so you know
sorry but hopefully it makes sense so
this is a simple search what I have is a
bunch of students taking Python or Java
and basically I took all the users from
Stack Overflow so this is a very small
subset so I recommend that you take if
you have time download the code you can
download these users from Stack Overflow
which could be millions or you can
actually take a post which would be in
millions and millions and upload that so
I have strips that can upload Stack
Overflow data so just run it and you can
test it out of yourself right and then
so it's a simple search I've given
options the good old search is which is
a light class you can see on the right
then you got the full text search quasi
search and sound deck so a simple thing
like David I'm gonna search for that
pretty fast about I have a habit out
like almost million records in there and
it took about 0.7 nine milliseconds
literally that's fast
in my opinion so and it's doing it
across tables too so you can see that
actually a David is username Python is a
course name and if I do it like it's
about 2.8 million seconds are still fast
but you can see the difference between I
don't know if you guys can see that
getting I see it I get so the difference
is pretty drastic when you do a simple
life and that like moves uglies and I'll
show you in a minute but but just the
full-text search it's pretty routine
don't be fast and the other things you
have noticed one thing is that I'm
ranking it but Python so all the guys
are taking David and rolled the Python
are coming on the top if I change the
ranking I'll still get David but I'll
get Java boosted on the top does that
make sense right so if you look at the
bottom you will see guys were initially
who are on the top now at the bottom
because I rank them differently but they
still match to the results so this
happens all the time another platform we
need to show users that are ranked by if
they are taking English and there are
the middle level English reading we need
to show them boost results which are you
know care to that specific core
curriculum I don't know that you know
anything about education but but the
point is that we need to show data
relevant to their in a profile so it
could be any profile in this case if I'm
I'm a Java person I want to rank them by
Java so that's a simple search going
back to the any questions
so this so this whole project is
basically this is an angularjs project
so it uses angularjs in the front all I
have is an interceptor that actually
makes a call every time we make a treaty
we call it just calculates the time
taken between two of the requests so
that's what we do so yeah so that's just
sort of things that I kind of talked
about and I'll come back to this and
this but the last point is that the the
table
think about the table the way we
restructured it is very similar to a
search engine they're going to use so
for example if you're using solar or
using Spinks or using elasticsearch you
have to create an index which is a very
common thing for any for anything you're
gonna do you need an index in the
similar manner you need to update that
index every time there's a new record
that's been added let's just say someone
adds a new student someone adds a new
course some student enrolls in your
course you do not want to update on the
main thread so if someone and somebody
says I don't want to take that course
anymore up you want to do it you want to
offload that work to something else
because trying to update a table and
trying to update the index will take
forever
it doesn't matter his close residence
doesn't matter if it's if it's any other
index so always always always use celery
actually you started it for everything
to be possible it's good for help too
but the point I'm trying to make is that
you want to offload all of your lap'
large tasks into into something
accelerated that make sense so what
celery does it updates the search table
so that is available for searching the
only downside with this is that those
results not gonna be latest so if you if
you just enroll and if you search for
your name you might not be available in
the search result which is a common
theme across all search engines whether
you take the best sociation at Google
you're not gonna see the latest results
right away it will take some time for
them to index
okay so before I go into into the whole
like behind what's happening in Postgres
it's gonna highlight some indexes so the
two indexes we're going to use today is
genin Geist let's talk about just for a
second so the weight just works is if
you take a document document could be
simply a name of the person and droll
for a class it breaks down
individual words into hashes of their
own okay and then it ORS them to create
a big strength all right
so that's basically what hash-based just
indexes Jin on the other hand uses be
trick how many of you actually know B
tree here oh look do you know there's a
lot of people possibly a B trees a
shallow tree but it has a wider width
right so the reason why it does that can
anybody tell me why does that like why
isn't it like a binary tree which is can
go as long as possible why does it go
wider but not in vertical it's very
shallow anybody somebody raised
everybody raised to be tree they knew it
come on right so that's by binary tree
does that too right but binary tree can
go as long as possible but betrayed
right so beach is very shallow so you
only try to do nodes horizontally it'll
never go over to Cle up the entire
CouchDB how many people couch couch TV
yeah it's all based on B tree so it's
literally a b-tree the reason is because
when you take a be free index the the
biggest problem with any disc is that it
tries to seek a sector right so when you
try to read a sector that's aware that
the most time is spent right
so if you can make the index or at least
you can make that node as big as the
sector itself when you read it the whole
note gets loaded in with the memory from
that point on it's extremely fast to
seek that note does that make sense so
if you go to go vertical we can't do
that because then the nose will be
spread out onto multiple discs but with
a whip with the wider node you can
actually put that entire thing on one
sector it's just much faster to access
so I'm in any sense or just assume it's
fast okay take that with me but so with
with these things you get so but the
problem of the beech tree is that the
update time is a little longer because
since it has to really a big the entire
sector they takes a lot more time than
just and then would you get three times
more speed and the size is the same
thing because you're getting a bigger
size so it's a sake of this argument
just use Gen just don't go to Jess just
it's just much easier to do that so
now certain things I'm going to
introduce into context here but do not
be afraid this is this is not nothing to
do with Postgres but it's just the way
any search engine works which is it
takes the word the document that you
give it to it and the stem said
basically just make sure that normalizes
the text what I mean by that is you can
see this text how much wood wood chuck
chuck wood I could never say that no
matter how many times try it but the
point is it will normalize that text so
we can see here it will remove stop
words stop words which are such as the a
a I will normalize those words will
remove you know you will it will convert
them into lower case we will singular
singular eyes them big positions
available which is very common concept
both stemming which happens in every
search engine okay so if you ever looked
at can you guys see this or is this to
borrow it so it just takes bunch of
words and convert that into a search
engine concepts which is called stemming
and if you look at solar to look at
elasticsearch or leucine which is where
it all solder will do the same exact
thing okay any questions
what are you talking about get some work
somebody's downstairs
somebody's downstairs want to get up and
being there's topic to be paying
attention yeah thanks
so yeah so that's what he does
so we need to do that just like hobby
what he would do with any other search
engine you're gonna have to do it and
then lastly Whitney search for something
you need to convert that search term
into the normalized stat so you can see
here I don't know they can see anybody
see that but basically what you did with
these vacuum and you have to do with
this is search query also but this is
just information is good to know you're
not never gonna ever have to write this
so in the sense that this is done in a
very good package called Django ORM DJ
ORM so use that if this is just to make
sure that you understand what's
happening so once the data is inverted
and a I will tell you what this is
just curious we noticed something
there's a numbers associated in there
the word sentence I'm sorry isn't the
index for the working sense yeah so it's
the positions yep so basically is just
saying that these words are there at
that positions that's what like plural
does they care about singular plural
yeah so it converts everything into
singular wait so how is yeah so this
stop words are not included so it uses a
Dictionary of English dictionary we can
actually convert that into a specific
language so it has multi-language
support that I forgot to mention so if
you are french-speaking you can still
use this but yeah so it single arises
that into into words
so you can see here at the bottom I said
chucks and it will Singler eyes that and
then we'll make sure you'll map that to
they'll give you true for that but you
have to convert that into normalize that
as well normalize it you wrote Chuck's
but if you wrote Chuck would stop buying
it so if here if it so Chuck yes it
would but you need to convert that
because it's if you want to just make
sure that if you're using any plain
English tom search like if there we did
good Chuck Chuck then you want to use
that TS but they works both ways so if
you have plural decisions or pluralism
yeah it doesn't matter what you put in
here assuming that in the world yeah
single arise it so so yeah so I mean you
don't really need index but you always
you know through the large tables it'll
be very slow but if you want to ever run
a select statement you can just do that
this is very straightforward thing so
what we do here is we're gonna create an
index we can actually create an index
based on just a few columns you can see
here at the bottom you can actually take
two columns or don't have to do it one
column so that's the beauty of that's
called document so you'll notice that
when you use any of the search engines
they'll ask you to create a document
which is a composition of multiple
fields like a first name last name their
age or whatever you call it and that
that becomes a document you can actually
do that right here which is awesome so
so we'll just quickly look at that code
so that what I just talked about is
basically that search right here which
is so I'm using South how many of you
actually stopped using DD is at one
point seven that has the migration thing
now yeah how's that is it a phone or is
it just a learning curve or
how many people have used it so far at
one point yeah I don't know because I
haven't even looked at it
is it okay so i'm using south i love
stop but so it's the basic idea is that
you create in south you just simply
create an empty migration which is being
probably have done a thousand times and
what you do is you just basically add a
a feel like that it's just base to be
executed you just say the table that you
want it and then the the column that you
want to put an index on that's all which
is and then all of the work happens here
so
so I may show it on your minds sorry you
can't so DJ so the reason I'm doing it
raw because I wanted to show what how it
looks like but if you use GJ ORM they
actually do that automatically find the
same thing I have a slide on that but
but you can actually create and then I'm
going to contribute to it too but the
whole fuzzy searching but it has a field
called vector field which converts that
into the proper that's a great question
so if I just show you the model for a
second so this is a model that I created
and which I call the document if you may
right so you don't have to create it you
can actually still use an existing you
know a model that like a student of the
course but what I want to do is I
already create a model called student
full-text search which is basically is a
list of three fields one is a student
this is one to one field which we
already know the title and we'll come
back here in a second and then the the
field the searchable field that we just
talked about which is the actual
document which contains the you know all
the concatenated data but you want to
search for so you can concatenate it you
can concatenate the name of the person
the course their age the location they
you name it right so it could be
anything and you can have as many fields
as you want and you can create
individual indexes on that so you can
one model can actually have six fields
six different documents and six
different indexes on that it's perfectly
OK alright so you can have n number of
fields that can be searchable and it can
use all of them that make sense
so how do I so I have if somebody signs
up and some certain signs up for a
specific course how do I update this so
basically what I do is I use celery and
basically what I try to give as many
confident comments as possible so
hopefully it doesn't make sense but all
the celery is doing here is basically
updating the table at the end so all so
it's preparing the document DB so this
is this document I don't whether you can
see that but can you can you zoom in
make the text yeah
this way
command+ yeah
good good enough for her to be amazed
how small I keep my found but I am more
space at this display last time
that's Lucy that looks really operation
okay or should I just go back what's the
other one we're stretching the screen
hold on the function key and the one
next to it and then I know
sumit a trackpad you hold down function
and the key next to it and then you zoom
it attract that no squint I guess what
I'm trying to do here what I'm trying to
do here is I'm actually preparing the
document itself so you can see I'm doing
first name last name and the course name
you can put anything you want you can
put every any document concatenation you
want like anything that you want to be
searched on you can concatenate that
into a field that's all you need to know
that's all I'm trying to show it's a
simple join at the end I'm just joining
that into a string but the idea behind
is we create a column which is a TS
vector you add the fields that you want
to get searched on and you clearly index
on them that's all you're gonna do
that's important and when you look at a
code it'll be prettier than that and you
do a search on that field that's all so
so he does a very good job I'm doing
this but
why do I have to do this which is what
is said the transaction dodi here and
the owner they could see that
okay everybody tell me that why do they
have to set the transaction dirty when
I'm actually running an update statement
and Django no they're still running
celery right so reruns under so on
almost like a management command right
so it's loads up a different process
loads up the day of the race loads up
everything as if you're running a
management command it's just that it
happens to run itself and sorry you used
to look at the somebody look at the
this is your celery file and all you're
doing here is that you're just saying
start the celery and look for all the
install tasks and you're just passing in
the setting spot that's all you're doing
but she's really running it as an admin
commander at some point I mean I'm all
over seems to find that but but I have
to do this for
some reason
it's because you're running when you're
running the cursor I don't know what the
Hobbit will notice that but when you run
a cursor and any time you execute
something you have to set the dirty just
let Postgres know that you're updating
something so because you started a
transaction here okay when you when you
see a transaction and commit here it
starts a transaction but you updated
something on the Postgres and if you
don't issue a commit after that you're
gonna end up having a situation where
there's a rollback automatically or is
gonna throw an error depending on how
you set the post we're setting up so but
the reason we want to do this is because
we want this to be atomic we don't want
we don't want halfway through this and
fails and then be like oh [ __ ] the
database is the search is corrupted so
you want this to be atomic but since it
initiates a transaction write a new
transaction you need to finish that
before you leave but the cursor has no
Django has no idea that the cursor
executed because it has no you know
concept of oh I gotta commit this that's
why you need to set that dirty because
none of the models in here there's no
model here I don't know whether you can
see that but there's not a single model
that it's been set to dirty and that's
why you need to force-feed it saying you
want dirty go commit yourself why not do
it the other way just do a manual
transaction and you your own miss manual
it's getting labyrinth all of it just
trans actually commit you could do that
- yes you put that in a put that in a
try-catch block right so you do a try
you say transaction initiate right and
then you do success on the right before
it except and then in the rollback so
you can do that - it's just the reason
I'm doing this is because you don't want
the rope do you want to roll back ever
yes because you want each one like yeah
because you're trying to run this every
time a student course happens right so
the way you call that is
from here which is
which I have right now for those
uploading data I was
you can see I'm calling it as as a delay
so that pass that delay which pushes the
on to celery and now at this point it's
completely different transactions you
could do that if you can force the model
like changes something in model and save
it it will then automatically understand
that there's a dirty black set and
they'll do exactly this is a direct
update to the database literally just a
corset update so when you yeah so
basically what I did just now is I so
again you're running through the thing
you create a model which is a brand new
model which is pure text for searching
purposes only
you create a feel that actually can
store your concatenated set of fields
that you want to be searched on and you
turn it indexed once you do that
basically that forms and then you run a
sell your tags that are going to date it
and then at the last you do is you
basically do a search on the term itself
which is this where a column name this
is a special PostScript on called a tap
plane to query and then you search for
that and that's it gonna get you're
gonna get all the rows that match with
that specific query any questions
and you do that with the model here so
that you get the models bats who do you
don't have to use the cursor here you
can just use a model of extra that way
you get actual models back in in your
query see some blank faces I just want
to make sure you guys guys are it's not
database I know it's a little bit heavy
database heavy but I just want to make
sure that you understand the
fundamentals because if you start using
Django ORM you will you don't have to
deal with all this you basically the way
you deal is the model dot search give
the search text dot rank and you
basically just work as if you're working
with models that method name you never
you never have to do this again because
there is only a package that does that
so I just want to make oh yeah yeah what
I'm saying is oh yeah really cute so so
that would be something like you would
create my you create a vector field that
I talked about so you don't have to ever
create a blank migration and clear that
field you can just simply say a vector
field and you can just create the source
models and you can see here you can say
student course that objects that search
and that actually does a full-text
search for you so you don't have to
write that that ugly sequel if you may
so boosting so this is we saw a just a
moment ago where you boost certain
results over other people so if I want
to do Java I can do on the top if I want
to do still pretty fast which is over
Python and you again do that with using
a concept es ranking so yep so here all
I'm saying is that if you find in the
document a word just put that on the top
that's always doing it's not filtering
it's just saying that if you do find
that search term in that document just
push it on the top above the other
people because we do that like if you
want to boost seven results or where
other people you can do that
or you can you can put anything you want
here it could be Python it could be time
let's just say you want to return
documents at our latest documents so
let's just say you have one million
documents and somebody searches
somebody's name but you want the latest
documents on the top how what are you
gonna do on that any any ideas what
would you do in that context so you did
a search you did a TS vector it gives
you all the results of the documents
that actually has matching documents
right so you got let's just say 100,000
documents how are you going to give that
to the user you need to show them the
latest results right so you need to show
them these are the latest documents or
the old documents but well how would you
go about doing it how would you rank it
by
the decorated day right so that we one
way of doing it or update it so you can
you can you don't have to use TS right
you can simply say by order by and then
you can give just an updated by date
that's that simple so it it still takes
into account the normal order by so you
can just use your typical that order by
method in your Django model is that
simple so you can use whatever ranking
that you feel that you've been using
today you don't have to use TS rank but
you can still just resort your normal
ranking that you would want in your
search results okay so ranking is a very
interesting thing because sometimes you
want to certain documents to come or the
tops for example you want the documents
that I have title come above the
description command world attack I don't
know how many people actually have this
kind of requirement but if we ever
search the stack or floor comm or
advanced searches that you saw in
LinkedIn they will have like you know
search for this person in this education
field and this specific like sales
department or that's actually my point
I've been looking for a lot of sales
guys but if you're looking forward to
Stack Overflow for a Python to you know
specifically Django you can actually
select that they'll still give you all
the results related to Python but the
Django once will will have a higher you
know relevance ranking because you
search for that term okay so what you
can do here is you can set weights onto
that again this all of this is done in
Django so don't have to do this ever
again but I'm just giving it so that you
get the idea what's happening
yeah so you want certain documents
certain results to come above the other
results that's all you want to do not D
not the the boosting this is where if
you find something in X and you find
something in Y I want the X to come up
higher that's all trigram how many
people know try and RAM like algorithms
and grams try Gramps
ok I'm been talking for less last hour
so maybe you did and you haven't been
using it or that mean it's like the
trigrams three words or three exactly my
grammars and why would you use that
just curious and that's thought it is
four so you basically look for hallo
hallo or whatever you know people make
mistakes in their spelling so you can
see when you do a trigram which is a
very simple algorithm it breaks down the
letters into subsets like that and all
that does is it depends on how many
letters that match to your search tongue
so you can be typing in a spelling
mistake and it actually will break those
words down and find out how many similar
results that you have and it's extremely
fast I mean think about it this is not a
like it's not a regular expression shirt
you're actually typing in a wrong word
and it actually gives you the words that
are actually so close to it and an
extremely blazing fast speed okay so to
show that I hope or to claim I made it
works so
that was fast this is one millisecond so
I type in the red and then the soundex
basically gave me David like that cuz I
made a mistake in the search results so
it just basically just gave me something
that's related closely related to it
this happens so many times in our
platform that 80% of our searches are
actually similarity searches or soundex
searches literally so you can tell the
state of education people don't how to
spell in school I mean I know but still
like they're searching they're searching
within correct terms I mean what people
getting lazier yeah it's just that I
don't have the trust amazing and then
that's what we're doing right even lose
so many indexes we're trying to use so
many trigram parsing so that we can give
more other than results but it's pretty
fast and this is again going through a
million records in about a millisecond
this isn't my local machine doesn't have
that much juice that yet is running this
fast imagine we can run it on a full m1
Amazon large machines alright cool
so yeah so the way we use is something
of the function called similarity and it
always is probability
basically it says if you have zero it's
no match if it's 1 it's an exact match
so you just have to adjust this every
day so you can look at the if you look
at the my similarity index so it's 1 to
10 so you can say 1
it'll probably give you you know these
results if you say let's just say you
know you say 8 it will just give you 0
results because you're trying an 8 is
like extremely tight again I want to
make sure this word matches 80% of the
time in this case it doesn't so so you
can adjust that we have a back end where
we constantly monitor how many searches
are made especially searches that
yielded zero results we constantly look
at that we also look at the results that
been returned
but then this one says I couldn't find
what I'm looking for so anything that
triggers off of no results or results
that students cannot find we constantly
adjust the the fuzzy search and we
constantly update our index s we we do
is we add indexes on the fly and I'll
show you how to do that but yeah so and
then last I talked about the soundex
which is the oldest and kind of only
works for English names basically so my
name is definitely not an or so and
basically what it does is that it can
it's the oldest algorithm it converts
the letters into a for length
alphanumeric character so you can see
here I made a mistake with the E in the
extra but the soundex comes out to be
exactly the same this has been there in
Oracle from day one so most people would
know this but so this it's easier
because you can it almost sounds like it
so that's what sound access you can use
that as often as you want the beauty of
that is you can actually bake bake the
entire sound X into an index itself how
cool is that so you literally have an
index of off the unique words that you
want so you can actually have an index
separate index thick indexes as a files
like in solar or in
in in in elasticsearch like you can
create as many indexes as possible in
those search engines in the same manner
database index is the same thing it's
just a file and you can have as many
index as possible so what we do is we
create indexes of unique unique words so
if we can't find it even after
similarities we go search there and then
give them are you looking for this so
you can see how Google does that all the
time or equal to Yelp you go to any
other search engines to tell you like we
couldn't find it but you never want to
give zero results ever this bad for
engagement right so you always want to
give them we couldn't find it did you
mean this all the time it's very
critical so yeah so that's that and that
code is here as well because you can see
the simple soundex function so that just
basically takes a term and again you
there are you're gonna be adding to the
Django ORM all of these functions so you
never have to actually call these things
so the only thing that right now is the
vector T s vector so you can do a
full-text search right off the back with
poet is short but it does it doesn't
have the ranking and the boost thing and
all the things I just talked about so
we're gonna be adding there soon and the
last but not least the that's the ugly
like I was talking about
I'll move this to
so as you can see this is just trying to
search for the first name of the last
name and the course name across multiple
tables you don't want to do this ever
just never do that
and we're don't join multiple tables
you're just going to kill the our
database and kill the users so just use
a better search engine doesn't have to
be Postgres the reason we went to
Postgres is time-to-market right so we
really wanted to go to the market
yesterday and and nobody in this team
new search or elastic search I mean just
the setup itself is just so difficult so
somebody said just using Postgres and
then here we are talking about post
research so the pros are obviously you
know Cooke implementation a lot easier
to change the document format again
create index whenever you want to just
you know don't be hesitating you know
speed is definitely comparable to search
engines I mean it's really fast a very
cost effective because one database or
one less system to worry about like even
try to do solar just the the constable
itself is so complicated you it gives
you all these bells and whistles but
it's just not the everyday thing you can
do very cost-effective and the set is
not flexible but you can still work
around it
it's obviously tied to pause right so if
you ever switch database I mean who the
hell switches database and halfway I
mean I don't see anybody does that but
you could if you aren't that brave
please go ahead and do it and indexes
can get a large but that's the case with
any other you know search engine so the
the only issue you're going to find is
where elastic search is phenomenal is
basically cluster searching right so
posters database is one index to one
database so if you have so many people
searching you're gonna get a bottleneck
soon right so because it's one database
with elastic search is charge so but all
the indexes are spread out so there's a
master there's a replicas so basically
if it finds that there are you know
multiple requests coming in relax or try
to spray it across so you actually get
really good performance but now
sometimes the the master and the
replicas could be out of sync but that's
not so not a big deal
if you really think about it talking
about using replicated elasticsearch
yeah you could do that too
I mean you could the gaudiest allows you
to a replicate I mean hopefully they'll
lab that student but you can have a
Charlotte postcodes database we're just
gonna go that route just go with yeah
you can have that too but I'm gonna for
that but I'll just go with elasticsearch
yeah it's just so much because they're
it's a community's adding a lot of
features to it there are very specific
research so just it's just much easier
to just use if any gonna go Enterprise
but so so the Django ORM which is this
github link supports full full-text
search right now literally so you can
today I can go home and write it right
or index write a search and it'll
actually work for you today okay
the hope is as we go as you can see it's
a simple let's do that's all that donkey
saw TS record and all that crap is not
it is all taken care of inside but
obviously it's a post rest I highly
recommend look at other projects under
this line they have amazing like
Postgres pooling which you should all
always be doing you should always pull
your databases there is a connection
mind ring for for your database
connections so it will give you an email
if you're above certain connections on
your database but how many of you here
actually use pooling in a database like
like really big pooling what do you use
so connection pooling is that are you
using Postgres or is it okay yeah PG
balancer okay how many of you actually
using RDS or any variation of an Amazon
databases anybody it's like the DynamoDB
Oh which one dynamo how iOS are coming
out great it's too expensive I mean some
of the numbers that they have is amazing
so but the next steps are you know add
all these things that we just talked
about so our hope in the future you can
do something like this you can set that
search you know we know how Jango
programmers like to see their code so
obviously that search then do a rank
then do fuzzy search in the soundex then
do a rank and suppli
which is very pythonic which you know
and then I'm going to continue to add
code Postgres search so you guys can
take a look at it so what I did is it
actually is a full end-to-end so it has
angular gears to the front end celery in
the back
Django what six I think and use a South
so some tips if you you can use the
separate TV just for indexing you don't
have to use the master database but
first of all you can do that you can
literally just step it out you know and
put it on a different machine altogether
if you want to it'll always feel like is
an engine this is very important don't
index everything to networks
you don't want index everything you want
to limit your indexes so for example if
you have 1 million users out of which 5
of them are active which is the case
with all startups today you don't want
to index everybody right so you want to
index only those people so you can
actually while you're creating an index
you can say create index where user date
is around
time which could be like today's day or
like a date - 30 days into that so if
you can only index those people are
acting the last 20 days because of that
is indexed and I get updated constantly
better which is not that bad because it
does it very well you know as happening
in the back side while what people are
reading the index they're gonna keep
continue to get the old results while
it's updating index so which is still
okay with it I'm fine with that
and you can use Postgres analyze and TS
that this is what we do now a lot which
is we create indexes concurrently so
what happens is a lot of times we know
they're new such requirements people say
hey we want to search on this search on
that but we don't have indexes for it so
what happens is we sometimes see this
which scares the hell out of us which is
this is the literally the cost to run if
we don't even use an index and I don't
know how many of actually do explain
plans and databases but every database
comes with that but the cost is pretty
high literally just this is a very high
you can see it's tries to do a lot of
hashed conditions and goes on and on and
on and on until the sequence of scan
which is horrible
and then another sequential scan which
is another horrible thing to do so when
you see this you've got to be like
getting up and running somewhere because
this is not good so what happens if you
use if you use a simple TSV vector
pretty nice it uses bitmap heap scan
which is pretty fast like don't be fast
and the cost is just barely anything so
it's really look at that time that's 1
million records right there five minutes
you can't beat that the rest of the time
is spending Django Howe and angularjs so
so good this is the this is the time
spend by the database actually so what
you saw in 1.2 or 0.8 milliseconds
that's all just angular and Django doing
there
and she's aware that all they do this
yeah I know they're pretty good but
they're at time to the oral execution so
and the last one is don't pull your
foreign key objects and your searches
don't do that there's no reason why you
should be pulling that try that's why we
have a title so use the title which is a
document title to show the users what it
is and concatenate or put IDs in there
and concat make a URL out of it right so
when I'm doing this in this screen this
this comes directly from the single
table what I have that is student ID I
can actually prepare a URL using I know
the URL right I can set a / student / ID
I can prepare the URL so there's no
reason for you to pull when you're doing
searches never pull additional tables
never don't do that it's not healthy so
just try to like concatenate so putting
enough information like IDs in your
database on that table so that you can
actually concatenate and create our IDs
and that's what you do with your solar
or elasticsearch the elasticsearch will
ask you or so it will ask you what is
the data that needs to be searched and
what is the data that you need to store
so that when I actually find it I can
give it to you and you usually would add
things like ID of a student ID of the
course
idea of that that's what I'm trying to
do here that makes sense
okay and
so that's me and you can reach out to me
anytime you want
so I've been trying to get to that but I
couldn't
sorry but uh yeah so so hopefully all
you guys use Postgres because I you know
there's no reason why you should not use
Postgres and don't use my sequel and but
you should louise mom but i use it for
for mostly for you know chatting and
data that i don't care about that much
if he's not transactional so but it's
it's a it's a RDS hopefully that's more
I just said the replica and slave and
read-only represents which would be even
better it's a little expensive but as
long as I'm not doing devops I'm more
than happy to do so so any questions
it's like the currently you use Django
or to build your tables are you menu the
customs building your create cubes so
Django ORM does the dusts some of the
building so you can use a South Eve
actually look great at es perfecta feel
like a currently free mixes they won't
do oh no Punk run you have to do it like
suppose you have to notice it yourself
because you know what fields you are
searching on right so all you have to do
is you just have to created other index
which has that subset of data basically
so what's an example when you apply it
concurrently like you basically you look
at in this needs to be the basic stuff
that keeps right yeah so when you bring
in to Colonel so you're saying you look
at the explained plans you see
something's being hit what so but you
never use regulars next I'm trying to
figure out when would use and curly so
if you want to add a brand new index
under this different start stuff so
another field maybe so for example they
we have another table that actually has
the data they've been looking for so we
want to bring it into document then
you're gonna redo the index itself or we
are to recruit a brand name index so the
old searches will still function I'm
saying so at that point when we create
that index so it will try to the what
posters will try to do the look slug
what index is available which is which
index is more cost-efficient and it will
use a quality of that index depending on
how you you know depending the cost
studied can't wait that explain it but
what made you decide to make something a
concurrent index first because they
don't want the if you if you try to
update the index the they won't use
index oh just go to table scan basically
it will it will not it will just
completely ignore your you know TSV
vector I will just not work at all
because when you default one yeah yeah
yeah so you can't I mean with
concurrently what happens is your it's a
read-only at that point so indexes still
can be read but it'll still be all data
but once you choose to live but then you
get faster yeah
so you just so you don't have a down
time basically so would you know if
you're not worried about having snail
data every little bit yeah why would you
always think incorrect because this is
well as if we are in production right so
let's just say we are going to
production today or tomorrow then you
you don't need to run it concretely cuz
you don't have any data if you are you
should I mean in that context yes like
if you aren't production if you are
actually running data if you have a
million records more than ten records
for that matter you should always be
using Cochrane of course but this is
saying that if you're building something
right you don't need to use controller
there's no reason to was you already
built a index and then it'll just update
it because a post Chris will update that
automatically every time there is a new
record that's been added to it but even
like you said like updating it it's
gonna be slower if it's a regular
versatile Kirk because otherwise for the
for the right to complete the trades
actually close the index has to get
updated too right yeah but it doesn't
automatically brandy on decks yeah yeah
absolutely it wasn't fair that yeah so
it's only when when you say create index
concurrently that's only when you're
building a brand-new index but when
you're when the record is updated let
you see you add a new record and the
index has to be updated pause you guys
takes care of that okay so good thanks
that Twitter handle goes nowhere
Oh agile secret oh I misspelled it and
right away so my badge on that really
cool yeah keep it keep you keep it like
just make that your new Twitter handle
part of me wants to steal it
any questions I mean I how many of you
actually have the bad you know I'm sorry
yeah I wouldn't know that right yeah
that's right so I mean so okay so that's
a good question so what you want to do
is and this is what we do is when we do
a full text search in the beginning we
see there's no results that came up we
go to unique index and see if there's
any matching worse for app and then use
that search and if that doesn't come out
then we go to sound exit yes change
because it depends again like the entire
premise is based on you do not want
people to see blank results but because
that is horrible because they you know
it's engagement and all that fancy
metrics for that yourself
yes does it ever take into account like
people because sometimes like I'll type
a word I'm not looking I'm completely
shifted over like one could you give me
an example I'm sorry yep right so so
that there's an algorithm for that I
hope I'm pronouncing it right Levenstein
levenshtein here so it finds out how
many edits does it take to replace one
word with another word so a smaller
length is is very comparable and like as
the distance grows higher and higher
it's not very similar so is that taking
few letters ultimately yeah so I've so
exactly so so you compare that against
your works
oh you literally just like it doesn't
make any sense at some point yeah so use
that's why you use levenshtein stamp it
finds in the number of edits it takes to
replace one string with another string
no I don't think that's what she's
talking about if your hands when they're
oh yeah I don't know I mean you probably
will give a completely random results
because the sound X or the similarity
would be not even close yeah so because
the the the the vocabulary would change
I mean the way the word sounds will
change and the similarity will change
it's not that smart sorry I wish it was
yes absolutely I'm so sorry I didn't
mention that it absolutely supports
boolean operators so if you if you look
at the thank you for bringing that up if
you if you look at the the Django thing
if you look at the search these are all
or operators you can use ampersand or so
you can actually have multiple words
concatenated if this user searches like
I want pizza or whatever you can
to tokenize that or we're gonna use
plane to query or you can actually use
yourself those things we want to so you
can support suppose Chris has regular
expressions built-in right so you could
which I didn't cover because I that
point became a prosperous conference so
but there is support for regular
expressions in the freakishly fast team
so if you again as I said thanks
Russians they build that really
expressions pretty fast so you could use
that you can bake that into actually
index itself if you wanted to so there's
a there's a very good documentation
available for that to like nine point
three comes standard with these modules
right now so you just have to create
extensions based on that so what do you
use like as you develop this stuff you
write to Django code you think you think
your query works then you run it in
angular in the front end you're like I
don't know so what do you what's your
typical approach I should see what
sequel generated so I'm going to use the
we used to use the Django debug toolbar
so which doesn't work with Ajax I don't
know what this still fix that you or not
have you guys is that still an issue
who's apparently doesn't spit out
queries when you do Ajax calls from
angular or that manages Ajax there's no
account of that but we print out korie's
so we have middleware that actually
prints out and if you're on stage dev
mode it prints out all of these sequel
queries that are been executed that's
the logging level yeah yeah so suppose
that queries and simply walks to the
right log file okay you just tell that
whatever yeah and then we take that and
we see if there was any results that
didn't come out through so we have
another interface that is a no js'
interface which basically what it does
is every time there is a record that was
not found it pings it creates a ping to
the node and says you know look at this
query so we store that query itself into
the database and we'll say but first of
all we push it to celery in the cellar
it goes to node and says sort of sorted
in the mango and then we look at
and say oh this question didn't it not
did not return results what the heck is
going on you know and then we come look
into that so is it is it data that
didn't exist or is it simply because
they use a type doing something wrong so
yeah
hey else I came up with so you kind of
talk to seasoned Django Python now you
celery get this while you know nodejs
what's that bringing to the table so we
use note for a real time chatting so
because we've been talking about it for
such a long time
can we move that into Django but I don't
know whether people are haven't
experimented enough I guess but they
uses note for mostly real-time
notifications so no such as chatting
like we use one-on-one chatting group
chatting notifying browser so there's a
new property new post is available for
you to view so it's like keeping up
those ports open so we don't own a
separate sub domain such that we can
push the browser's and say you have a
new new post or you have a new user
who's in the same cohort or something
that I don't know yep yeah parse is
great I mean I highly recommend you
sparse so parses we got no parse it's
got it's actually gotten empowered then
it yeah so I definitely know sequel
database on cloud basically right so we
used parts for we used parts for
notifications for APNs and google GCM
notifications such as you get push
notifications on your phone it's
extremely it was very cheap so I
it's a REST API so it really is the most
yep so you just basically do a REST API
call with the
your ID and you get push notification by
themself but I mean how if you want to
use like real-time have used firebase or
pusher how many guys no pusher pusher
calm if you go to pusher
it's pretty good it's all JavaScript
integration in the front-end you don't
ever have to do any more like the way we
did the node so just use a pusher calm
it's amazing all you're gonna have to do
is authenticate your user with pusher
and you talk about iOS no integration
right you talking about
Facebook and Twitter authentication yeah
but that's just you can Django
what is that Django authentication is
available right now I'm Jim social ah
Jiang was so shocked as all that parse
calm getting for free yeah I'm gonna be
a push notifications yeah but I mean I'm
just saying browser of notifications a
browser chat I don't know I don't think
so because it's purely SDK iOS and
Android X together but you could I mean
everybody everybody's doing it now so
they just it's just a flavor right I
mean anybody can no no this he does that
so I'm not I won't be surprising to do
it I'm just curious
yeah I just learned about it sure thank
well that sounds like a lightning talk
good for next time no I don't know